let's boil the three thousand year
history of work down to three minutes
first there were hunters and gatherers
everyone contributed and their business
was basically to survive eventually
people began to tame plants and animals
allowing for larger and larger
settlements this opened up new kinds of
work and if you were lucky pleasure in
these agricultural civilizations
powerful ruling classes emerged for the
first time in some cultures hard work
was seen as undignified
so it was outsourced to slaves servants
and serfs even though hard work made
those rich lifestyles possible in other
places hard work was seen as a virtue
one that signified a person's
contribution to society promoted group
harmony or pleased because for some
working hard became synonymous with
doing good and repenting for one since
where land was cheap and plentiful
families could establish their own farms
working the land took on a sense of
community all family members pitched in
depended on each other and their work
was never done in many parts of the
world agricultural improvements enabled
surplus crops to feed more and more
artisans living in cities and towns and
so came the craft stage of work like
shoemakers and carpenters all very
skilled and specialized then industrial
and capitalist revolutions changed
everything and brought with them
mass production new kinds of factories
demanded new kinds of workers all eager
to earn a living however they could in a
rapidly changing world some workers
banded together and took historic stands
for humane work conditions and demanded
all kinds of fundamental rights
including the 40-hour workweek
the development of computers the world
wide web and widespread education
assured us into the knowledge-based
economy while new opportunities are
available for some globalization and
other forces are leaving other workers
behind feeling like they can't get ahead
no matter how hard they try as fewer
people and fewer hours are needed to do
the work of yesterday people are
adapting again so here we are is this
the end of works evolution know how you
live and work will invent the future we
will work in order to eat you'll eat by
outsourcing food production to other
workers you'll tap into a deep human
drive to work on something and to make a
genuine difference doing it you'll rely
on your networks and connections to help
you out and you'll help others too
maybe you'll specialize in something
that no one has thought of before using
technology no one's seen before maybe
you'll make your voice heard among those
who find themselves excluded from
today's economy so keep on working
creating and inventing the future of
work
you